whatsapp e ripari e benvenuti simi
questo nuovo video ragazzi siamo stati
su gta era un sacco che non facevo gta
effettivamente comunque sto provando a
giocando sulla place 5 perché è sempre
gta 5 ovviamente ancora in 16 ce l'avrò
in anteprima mondiale ma non so ancora
se ai ragazzi ho visto che c'è una mappa
parkour che voglio provare a fare da
solo se riesco perché è un unico gli
slalom che devi fare in realtà li facevo
con la moto
se vi ricordate l'anno scorso però
questa volta ragazzi prova a farlo con
la mia bellissima che cast di macchina e
non lo so comunque una parkour
ma non sto vedendo il parkour dove sta
credo sia questo va bene tutto non è
vero tranquilli 66 calmo calmati porco
del demonio calmati
ok piano piano ragazzi io li odio e per
quello che mi mettono nancy e
incredibile sembra di stare ancora
all'esame di maturità piano bravo
perfetto buono buono c'è tutto questo e
abbiamo finito ho vinto no non ho vinto
vedo cose laggiù incredibile mi trova
molto meglio a fare parkour con le moto
se doveste dove devo andare qua si vabbè
cos'è oddio oddio l'acquapark
l'acquapark non è vero sono ancora in
piedi i nomi sono bravissimi ragazzi ma
che non è facile non lo dico per le
ragazze che sta ancora molto video va
bene e se riuscissi ad andare avanti
sarebbe incredibile va bene piano piano
piano piano tanto che c'è una rampa
incredibile ok poche ore che lo fa non
era facile ragazzi attenzioni sono
storto balene allora rifacciamolo e f
nei commenti ragazzi no dai dall'inizio
nom in chiara difficilino ragazzi non ce
la faccio drittissimo sono drittissimo
c'è la posta volta ce la fa
bravo poiché adesso lo presto adesso ho
preso questo non c'è ma social no sì no
sì sì piano piano piano piano a e piano
per l'amore dddd zaccaria
ok ok ok
dio ti ringrazio o final eight non devo
andare pure eppure velo
oggi è pure veloce devo andare pure mi
picchiano per il culo
devo andare vero quindi lo prende tutta
sta rampa devo farmela tutta di velocità
perché sennò non arrivò dopo c'è un
disastro questo livello
aspetta
di grazia ce l'ho fatta non ci voglio
credere aspetta aspetta aspetta
spettacolo si aspetta aspetta non c'è il
bello che i ragazzi non ci sono check
point cioè se non ci riesco dovrei fare
tutto voglio morire allora società
attimo che voglio vedere se riesco a
fare la sgommata iniziale che prende
velocità non so neanche se funzionava
bene ok ok ha funzionato amici non ci
credo allora piano che devo rivedevo
rifare tutta questa cosa di nuovo perché
non ne bastava una volta non lavori
facciamola certo c'è veramente chi l'ha
fatto non ci aveva proprio nulla da fare
dal mattino alla sera
eccolo perfetto ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho
fatta subito stava come possibile ciò
che su due ore prima adesso gioca da
subito
ok mi dai un cieco un check point per fa
guarda non chiedo niente a natale
prossimo 2021 non chiedo niente
dammi solo un check point adesso perché
per cortesia certamente sta mappa per
finirla devi riuscire a fare cose in un
millimetro quadro che non puoi farlo con
una macchina non lo faccio a piedi non
riesce se esco dalla macchina non riesco
a fare sta cosa a piedi gli devo farlo
con la macchina con la macchina va bene
bene è stato facile e rapido soprattutto
siamo arrivati fino qua per far quarto
insomma tutto sto casino tutto sto
casino per arrivare qua c'è per poi
rifarsi tutto da sopra c'è veramente a
in velocità la devo fare oddio mica non
avevo capito è andata bene non vedo
no non mi fa ripartire all'inizio mi
ammazzo ha per un attimo ci ha avuto
l'ansia di andare a sinistra c'è un
albero meno male che non era un albero
nord cactus giga meno male che c'era
questo perché sono cugat
ok devo andare qua sopra una donna che
disastro ti prego non cadere perfetto a
questa parte è una cagata e l'abbiamo
capito
meno male cerca artus e una volta fatto
questo come cacchio arrivo di sopra così
ce l'ho fatta sono fenomeno
bene bene bene bene bene bene bene bene
bene perfetto perfetto perfetto perfetto
perfetto perfetto le casse le buttiamo
giù perché siamo dei pro gamer
anzi è disintegrato ce l'abbiamo fatta
dove devo andare perché punti di la cosa
cos'è sta roba non dovevo andare lì mi
fai confondere porco demonio mi fai
confondere let's golf
perché rallenta piano o dio benedetto
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
perfetto bellissimo
bellissimo lo zio bellissimo che è bravo
e adesso che faccia non c'è cosa qua
bianco ok gobain ragazzo andando
abbastanza spedito e non vorrei
sbagliare ma teoricamente tutto giusto
ma donna si vede proprio che ho preso st
patente ragazzi ho fatto anche un
imprudente su gta disk il proprio come
bravo al fa vi ho detto devo farmi tutto
sto ponte tutto in speed up
il problema è che non so dove dobbiamo
andare perché se così li confondono
proprio ci prova jolo
va bene non so mai se devo farle
velociste parti o no perché non so se se
occorre velocità o meno va bene il
dubbio la rifaccio perfetto per ora
tutto ok per ora tutto ok
son riuscito a cambiare direzione e
velocissimo non so come dove vado lo
sapevo lo sapevo che mi frega la rai
clegg non so neanche un dio benedetto è
diventata una gara stunt show fatta ce
l'ho fatta ce l'ha fatta ce la faccio ce
la faccio sono fortissimo siamo rinati
all'aereoporto non sono anche come let's
go my brother adesso qua è abbastanza
qua abbastanza easy siamo arrivati ad
avere un da un millimetro di spazio ad
avere un chilometro di spazio mi sembra
giusto ok c'è una rampa league ormai sei
cose le prende in velocità ragazzi
perché ormai posso permettermelo però
non so neanche dove stiamo andando santo
iddio la vedo complicata questa ma ci
proviamo le top no direzione sbagliata
la ricetta sorella se permette ok
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai una sega
proprio una sega allora sta parte
ragazzi è veramente un disastro se posso
permettere che devo farla in velocità e
veramente un casino ora che in velocità
mentre cambia veramente un disastro come
la faccio ce l'ho fatta sono forte se va
beh ci sono arrivati madonna che ci sono
arrivato non ci credo ma dovevo venire
di qua sicuro c'è un birillo l'appunto
giovani va bene ho fatto cose strane non
non capisco dove devo andare
cos'è sta roba ok ce l'ho fatta
mamma mia che brutta robot fa ragazzi è
stato è stato un abominio è stato un
disastro su scala globale sta roba
allora vai piano santo iddio vai piano
che la macchina non ci passa di qua va
ok mesi va beh già era piccolo prima
come calcio faccio fast arola piano
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piace una roba no si va dai ragazzi
mentre proprio per meglio io proprio non
sono fatto per stan c'è veramente la mia
pazienza non esiste basta parte qua non
era la parte che avevo fatto prima il
contrario è arrivato alla fine prima
cioè prima e io ero riuscito ad arrivare
qua prima e raniero il cielo già acqua
io prima c'ero già arrivato ero andato
già alla fine io l'ho scoperto adesso io
potevo rimanere lì ero lo salta tutta la
mappa ci avevo fatta
no ragazzi ma veramente io ero arrivato
alla fine agosto al dato tutto ma va a
cagare
ma è un altra cosa ma dai ma verrà meno
ragazzi non ci credo
c'era arrivato prima due ore sono stata
pasti giri in merda questo qua ha fatto
delle curve che non sa manco lui ma dai
ma da le cose ragazzi momento e mi piace
iscrivetevi a chiara lasciato un
commento passato sul parkour che
vorreste che io facessi oppure mappe
particolari insomma sono sempre qua alla
scritta ai vostri consigli e noi come
sempre ci vediamo a un prossimo video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]